because did you play any piano before  rocket man no no and to be honest  i didn't really play that much in rocket  man i i tried you told me you learned  how to play all those songs you sat here  anything after the martini no  i did i did do quite a lot of learning  and prep and i do little bits in the  movie but only little sections but it's  quite intimidating when he walks in  isn't it yeah still maybe we do  something together i was actually just  thinking i feel like you  me and elton should be bffs just the  three of us  and we could you know go on like trips  and i love it i know he's in the middle  of a world tour but i think if we  propose it to him i think he'd sack it  off yeah let's do it  [Music]